you have great power even though you've
been raised as a human being you are not
one of them goodbye my son
hopes and dreams grow old you you'll be
an outcast I'll him
how there'll be a god to them
he saw what Clark did
you're the answer son you're the answer
to are we alone in the universe I just
keep pretending I'm your son you are my
son I have to believe that you were sent
here for a reason and even if it takes
the rest of your life
you'll owe it to yourself to find out
what that reason is
how do you find someone who has spent a
lifetime covering his tracks
for some he was a guardian angel
for others a ghost we never quite fit in
you will give the people of Earth an
ideal to strive towards
they'll rise behind you and it will
stumble they will fall
in time
they will join you in the Sun
in time it will help them accomplish
wonders
i Father believe if the world found out
who I really was
I'd reject me
he was convinced that the world wasn't
ready
what do you think
what's this damn door welcome back
everyone the CW just totally did the
thing there is a new Superman Smallville
TV show that's coming next year so I'll
explain what's going on they just
announced a whole bunch of news and
details and it's all gonna spin out of
crisis on Infinite Earths this year if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing an Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Superman moment from any
TV show or movie on the video the actual
Superman that they're doing is going to
be what you probably expected Tyler
hoechlin Superman with his Lois Lane
them probably raising their John Kent we
actually kind of got a teaser in last
year's crossover so I'll explain how
they developed it and how this project
originated and what it's going to look
like next year because they're using
crisis on Infinite Earths to change the
way that the multiverse works in the air
overs right now everybody is kind of on
a different earth with a couple of them
on earth one like flash arrow now
Batwoman and because they have Batman on
that TV show there is a Batman on earth
one too so but you would probably expect
there are a lot of people that are
theorizing that they're going to do the
world's live world's will die from the
original crisis on Infinite Earths in
the comics to fix some of those issues
why wouldn't you want all your heroes on
one earth but I'm so happy that they
finally confirmed my conspiracy theory
that I've had since last year's
Elseworlds crossover that they were
using the Superman scenes in the
storyline as proof of concept for what a
new Superman TV show would look like
there wasn't a ton of Superman
during that but relatively speaking we
had gotten so little Superman up to that
point that it felt like a lot like oh
wow
they're putting a whole bunch of
Superman in this crossover now during
crisis on Infinite Earths we have at
least three different versions of
Superman so they're going way overboard
obviously to set up this new Superman
Smallville reboot so to speak
technically it's not a reboot of
Smallville but it's their new Smallville
TV show that is the CW's favorite thing
to reboot or redo their old super
popular shows the whole idea was
Superman and last year's crossover was
that they established the tone of his
relationship with his version of Lois
Lane
introducing the Bitsey Tulloch version
and let you know how long they'd been
together how much she knew about his
life as Superman what the
amick was then they set up the idea that
they were about to get married because
he's proposing to her right at the end
of that in that little tag scene after
she discovered that she was pregnant and
this is all happening right after they
passed the monitors first test and saved
the earth from the book of destiny
Superman tells Supergirl that she would
have to literally and metaphorically
hold down the fort
solo make all the fortress of solitude
jokes that you want for a hot minute
because they were gonna have to go to
the safety of Argo city to give birth to
their baby they just kind of left that
hanging there they haven't referenced
that baby since then not even on the
Supergirl TV show this season so it's
like okay pretty big plot thread that
they have to pick up with during crisis
on Infinite Earths they posted a picture
of the crossover earlier Stephen amell's
daughter is standing right here in the
front this was one of the last days that
they were filming one person one really
little person was blacked out so a lot
of people like hey wait a minute
maybe that's the Superboy John Kent and
they just don't want people to see him
so early speculation the baby that they
said that they were going to have at the
end of last year's crossover is going to
be the John Kent from the comics he
becomes the new Superboy in the rebirth
comics if you haven't been a big comic
book reader the last couple of years
they had a long-running super Sons comic
book series with him and Damian Wayne
and even though they haven't said
anything about doing Damian Wayne in the
air verse anytime soon the basic concept
is a Smallville is coming up on its 20th
anniversary it's been that long since
the Smallville TV show debuted the CW
like I said is all about rebooting their
older most popular shows and there won't
be another Man of Steel sequel for at
least a couple more years there been
rumors about them doing another one in
another two to three years but arrow is
going away the flash also might be
ending after season seven or season
eight in a couple of years they need
another big comic book hit everyone
wants more Superman on their screens
both the movies and the TV shows why not
go for the easiest slam dunk in the
world and do a new Superman TV show a
couple of months ago when they started
to hype up crisis on Infinite Earths and
talk about how arrow was going to go out
in grand style they said that the CW was
developing a new superhero TV show and
they weren't talking about the arrow
spin-off TV show my hope was at the time
that they would do the no-brainer and do
the Superman TV show but sometimes they
make a really weird decision so you can
never really count on it but if
currently last year some of the people
on the flash TV show left after the
crossover to start working on the new
Superman TV show and it's been in
development since the Elseworlds
crossover so I think the only reason why
they sat on this news because they knew
that they were gonna do a new Superman
TV show for the past year was precisely
because arrow is ending and they didn't
want to overshadow that like Stephen
Amell is Oliver's gonna go out in style
and they didn't want to slap him in the
face by trumpeting out a new Superman
show early because the minute that you
tell people that there's a new Superman
TV show coming next year coming 2020
that's all anyone is gonna care about
the promise of the hot new thing to
bring all those elapsed CW arrowverse
fans back who quit the shows a while ago
next to Batman and Wonder Woman Superman
is the most important character in DC
Comics history if I were running a TV
network
I would Bend time and space to get as
much Superman in my universe as possible
so because they're using crisis on
Infinite Earths to set up this new
Superman TV show early plot theory we
have Brandon Roth who's leaving legends
of tomorrow as Ray Palmer he won't be
coming back to that show but he's going
to be playing Kingdom comes Superman
reprising his role from Superman Returns
and if you weren't aware that character
is also canonical II meant to be an
older version of Christopher Reeve
Superman because Superman Returns is
meant to be a sequel to Superman to
because they have a couple other
versions of Superman that I'll mention
in a second a lot of people are
wondering if he's going to be leaving
the arrowverse if he's going to be the
one Superman to sacrifice himself
because you gotta at least a couple
really really big alternate versions of
the characters during crisis in order to
make it feel meaningful aside from
off Oliver Queen or making it
seem like he dies who else could you
that seems that big obviously a
version of Superman or an alternate
version of Superman so he's just pretty
high on the list but if he doesn't die
they could always bring him back to
cameo on the new Superman TV show we
have Tom Wellings Superman coming from
the original Smallville series I don't
expect them to him off so he could
always come back and cameo on the new
quote-unquote Smallville TV show even
though technically it's not a brand new
small Bell TV show in potentially Dean
Cain Superman I know a lot of you have
asked whether or not he's gonna have a
cameo during the crisis on Infinite
Earths crossover they haven't said
anything about him but he's still alive
he's still able to cameo in
Hatcher is still alive - she's still
able to come back in cameo as her
version of Lois Lane but everybody post
your theories in the comments below and
how do you want them to bring back Tom
Welling on this new Superman TV show -
cameo every once in a while believe any
big questions that you might have in the
comments below or any big video requests
and remember there's a new flash episode
this week so while you wait for
everything click here for that new Flash
Batman crossover teaser and click here
for the boys season 2 trailer and new
characters breakdown thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight